you know he's so hip he's got a rope now
do you approve of the Rope for a belt I
do a Chris yeah what kind of jeans are
those bro
caller jeans our guys we have the same
coat on last night you know how much
it's costing I don't know I don't know
you know why just like my social studies
time looking man hey you what is that
yeah
dude what the [ __ ] bro what are you
doing man what are you doing take you
why you dress so [ __ ] regular because
I'm a [ __ ] regular man no it's not
rust rating in that sense I'm not some
Wallflower all right I'm not some
decorating for these [ __ ] sunglasses
on dude take them off your bird take
them off I won't
I won't hey happy bird take them off
right now don't call me happy you're a
happy bird take off right now dude what
are you guys talking about before I even
got here probably some [ __ ] like some
matter I could eat any
I mean 95% of men hold your whole career
and your whole persona is wrapped up in
your hair what happens if it falls out
dude I play interesting rules I start
playing interest are you losing your
hair I get real fat or I get my mean you
lose hair you get older but you know
lose you
I mean less hair than I have yeah but
you don't have a receding hairline no I
mean it's back there I got a bit you
know what it is I have a big forehead
period which sucks so if I lose any hair
I start looking more like I [ __ ] you
know yeah it's over what what let's do
some carnival you got small head you got
some all right
I do I know you got a smile as a
forehead first you have a small little
almond head don't write it sound it oh
yeah I put some cocoa on it don't you be
condescending I'm not but I'll put some
cocoa guests on this pocket
why the [ __ ] it's sewn that way do you
roll I don't you're sweaty Jane
it's how their shirts mean oh that's
actually not that big of a [ __ ] deal
bro rolling up your sleeve I I don't
hold it up it's stitched that way don't
wear those stitch shirts like that today
eyeing that this [ __ ] guy yeah this
guy I've had this shirt before I started
lifting weights you know don't you don't
have to show off your your weird arms
skinny fat my skinny fat yeah no matter
how jiggles look you soft you have you
have to crepin / annoyed them you did a
decrepit flesh no you have to generate
you have the flesh of a degenerate can I
be honest with you you have the skin the
look and the flesh of a pervert and I
may email listen of a street of a street
pervert not even a high-class pervert
you look like a street pervert whatever
dude
you do you look like a [ __ ] street
you hit a [ __ ] Tern event
sorry man look at that look at how
good-looking I was that's what they look
like but much bigger you look good huh
you're a good actor hmm a good actor
yeah yeah I mean I've been doing it for
25 years so don't say just say good
right so I'm there's a chance I could be
great right if I open up if I really
want it no but they say go they go like
you did go in casting rooms they'll be
like we get Bryan Callen and then you
know after everyone's like who's that
they go like now listen amigo like no he
was like that's because I get so lost in
the character you don't know me from one
role to the next and here's the other
thing you know that I can dig deep right
I can dig deep and there I am is the
Joker no Ryan you're you're not you
don't play the joke around Joker Moog
that's what is okay that's lying right
so that picture is lying right that
would just be a clickbait picture yeah
or or I'm playing the Joker I know it
says Bryan Callen cast in Joker right
there on the side everyone in okay I
don't know okay
right well you know cuz you did it right
yeah at any point in shooting did you go
hmm all right never mind dude you know
you lie so never mind yeah I've done a
lot of big movies dude there you go
there I am no that's not you that's
Joaquin Phoenix how do you know that oh
so I guess is of his face I guess that
picture is a lot is lying right yeah cuz
it's from we have a very sunny animated
times.com argue with them right right
okay argue with them don't be a dick but
my [ __ ] do I get the most hits on
your podcasts I don't know I do
Jenni does I mean maybe if you had
[ __ ] Ilan have you had like anybody
like Elon Musk but when it comes to
c-listers like me see this does like me
you get massive hit what are you what
level I'm an acapella I'm a mama imma
like at all imma like a Barry you're not
a sec I'm a baritone Shem ba ba ba ba
nobody I don't do duets I really don't I
do solo pretenses no I don't do it I did
see if you're singing I go like this or
like that but when you stop I go
no see you sound like a dog but I sound
like a [ __ ] dog
oh dude I had absolutely is gonna be 40
mm things are gonna die gonna die uh-huh
then hair falls out her hair so did
everyone in my family hope your dad will
just money because the well is gonna run
dry no no I mean yeah yeah fine you
become famous rough this like have you
become don't say I'm or more use the
word more in that sense well no if you
get like more like if you jump off a
bicycle game though but if you become it
if you become somebody that they want
for serious dramatic roles more roles
then what then what's gonna happen
you're just you can get real mad yeah
you're gonna get punched up don't with
no but like in yours like you can't help
it it's like a visceral no you're like
I'm on Chris when you get a big role do
you do you hesitate to tell Brian you
don't have to send me I've had my share
and I've turned my share down don't look
like that's something all right
don't raise your eyebrow okay okay ever
mind of its own but okay don't don't do
that okay I browse calm all right don't
[ __ ] have your caterpillars go crazy
all right but so I've turned roles down
I've chosen to keep my career where it
is right right like you like the private
life I have not fallen victim to the
public embrace of celebrity oh because
it keeps me focused and I do what it is
that I want to do stay humble I'd like
to spend your putting on it yeah no I
think it's a good thing it's all about
being positive
okay there's guys when they come in the
Comedy Store you know I'm saying like
your own the cow [ __ ] yeah man like when
you walked in one's like yeah
yeah oh cool thanks there's that guys
like Bryan Callen okay you're gonna you
took the compliment right oh right I got
offered that role that I did um in for
the movie from and that's a sony picture
I mean that's a huge move it's a big but
it's a drama so I was like well good on
the director from in the writing you
could do it it's also a leap of faith
because the character you're playing
yeah I mean make sense when I look at
you it makes sense okay yeah
like when I heard them like oh yeah
that's Chris yeah yeah actually guys I
know you're thinking we're thinking but
it's not a hero it's not a superhero no
that's not what they're thinking yeah
they were you'll never play a superhero
really dude really dude yeah you don't
think so dude
yeah I don't mind my [ __ ] striations
say otherwise don't you don't have
strike white zone dude I do have them in
my chest if I say whereas it would be
ridiculous I did [ __ ] dips yesterday
between two chairs and that's not that's
not a brag I know but I did until I
dropped practically oh you did seven
ignored my kids sit in the chair yeah
they were who have you seen laughs nope
they want actually like I was like move
daddy gets worse today yeah I got work
to do
and then I send you guys my workout just
- yeah it's don't you guys get little
come to comfortable well no I could eat
your weight you're dead lifting a
Smartcar it was too heavy it was too
heavy and I don't live in 25 got a car
and he's got terrible shoes and he's
eating oatmeal on some Jordan Air Force
Ones the original I know those are Air
Force Ones those little J's yeah it just
bothers me that you guys get I hate that
Chris does this he goes did we start
yeah all right what you hate yo show me
your shoes and you go there so dope they
oh you're a grown man you're 36 men I'm
young you're 36 I'll let you know when
I'm an adult how's that yo yeah at heart
I'll let you know when I'm gonna talk
who's that look I'm a kid bro I know I'm
just a little pup when do you think Oh
cuz we were talking so you know I mean
we're the [ __ ] experience comes into
me and then I [ __ ] shoot it out right
so I'm like this just happened to me and
then all of a sudden I've got
new minutes ago on stage I get a danged
angered a banger than a bang at a tonton
audience is like how do I [ __ ] did I
workout today and then the next day dude
I get a lot of times I get [ __ ] you know
emails none a lot of emails from that
way ya know and they go like this dude I
thought I was like did I workout
yesterday I was like oh yeah I went to
the Chris D'Elia show because my [ __ ]
core come on he's [ __ ] solid right
now
you know you shoot your food eat it uh
I'll just plants don't run I grab them
and eat them
yeah I'm with Chris on this all day I'll
just be care boy that's why you I would
go hunt and you would stay behind and
you would mash no dude
I'll tell you what I would do you know I
would be doing mash then I would go raw
water from the well no and you have you
would go out you would go home unpaired
how about this you present me with it
what about this said yeah big there'd be
a big welcoming back party you'd have a
dress on Uncle Dan oh that's actually
not what will be happening you know will
be happening while you're out hunting I
would be up in your girl's guts oh wow
about that by leaving it in Oh leaving
my god and then guess what and making me
raise your raise my kid clothing wise
your look like oh alright well your call
that's you in four years okay yeah kids
anyway I'm your dad oh uh you are so
awful hearin you know it you're a
ghastly human being leaving you know
what I am bro what sneaky huh that's
what everybody needs to know Chris
sneaky don't ya put 27 on it well I mean
you know put glue between
you'll be between 25 and 40 years
alright cuz when I think when you get 40
or in different brackets Oh Brian God
whatever [ __ ] are you saying that verse
sometimes just take a [ __ ] bath see
you're saying what we're saying only
with way too many words and after we
said it [ __ ] yeah guys sorry dude like
um no
like busting anchor yeah and your shades
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]